I want to take a quick look at how to  upload docker images to the Google  container registry first open the Google  developer console then select the  project you're working in and copy the  project ID now we can run docker images  to see the list of local images on our  machine I want to push the Go worker to  my Google container registry the first  step is to tag the image type docker tag  in the name of the image which is go  worker then type in GC r dot io / the  project ID slash the name of the image  type g-cloud docker push GC r dot io  slash project ID / name of the image  once you hit enter the image is uploaded  to the google container registry this  can take a few minutes depending on the  image size